[Applause]
I hope you don't regret that but let's
see yeah so um the the title of this
talk is beyond moments it's it's a
technical term moments as in you know
second moment third moment and so on um
and it's about a classical problem
robustly learning and a fine
transformation so it has some machine
learning it has an optimization problem
it has a new version of gradient descent
you're going to face a serious challenge
we'll overcome it with a common LMA I
don't know what what more drama you want
but okay um this is Joint work with
Heria who will graduate this semester
and she'll start as a postto at
Northwestern Titi and PES kotari whose
affiliation is CMU star okay uh this is
what
theim okay so here's the classical
problem problem um uh you get data and
you want to figure out the model what's
the model there's a product distribution
so each coordinate has been picked
independently but after picking that
that's s and then the data that you get
there's an a fine transformation applied
to it so a point is picked with
independent coordinates and a fine
transformation linear transformation
plus a shift is applied and that's the
data you get and your goal is just to
recover the fine
transformation so we'll see a geometric
picture in a second this is possible up
to the signs of the columns you know
because otherwise it'll flip the S as
long as at most one component is
gaussian if everything is gaussian you
can't do it right because the rotated
gaussian is still the same exact same
thing if there's a two dimensional G in
there rotations in there you can't tell
okay um and so the question is learn a
and z by observing samples I mean the Z
is easy right just take the mean of the
samples the a is the challenging one in
this case it's used all over the place
it was introduced independently many so
there are many attractive and puristic
that perform quite well in practice so
here's what it looks like
victori there's a cube we start with the
cube so that's a product distribution
uniform on unit intervals and there's a
sample but you don't see that you see
anine transformation of it okay so what
you see is that and you would like to
figure out what was the transformation
okay that's the problem good and so um
this is the problem learning a fine
transformation you see IID points from
and you want to Output an estimated of
transformation and your goal is to
minimize the total variation distance
let's say you could ask for parameter
you want to find the a to within a so
that the error of a minus whatever a you
get is small in some norm and so on but
this is going to be an even stronger
requirement that basically if you
applied your transformation and you
looked at the cube you say the original
was versus the cube that that's the true
one the difference should be at most
Epsilon
okay so the problem has been solved a
while ago um the in practice and also in
theory and one point of note is that
principal component analysis does not
work okay uh for example if a is a
rotation Matrix then the covariance of
the trans transformed distribution is
still identity so you get no
information like a rotated Cube you
won't be able to tell apart from a cube
so nevertheless the first step of there
algorithm is to make the distribution
isotropic so you know whiten it to make
the mean zero and make the Coan identity
and then this is the interesting step
find directions that are local Minima of
the fourth moment this so find
directions U so that I'm thinking of X
as the sample points that are given to
you and uh find directions that minimize
the the the fourth moment that's a hard
problem in general
but in this setting with these
independent original coordinates uh you
can actually find these well local
Minima you can find approximately in any
case and you can do it by grading
descent for example and the point is
that okay next slide um these are going
to be the facet directions the local
Minima are the facet normals that's what
Pro okay and that's just a on line proof
because you can rewrite the fourth
moment as the fourth moment along the
coordinates time this term that comes
from transformation plus a constant and
so the point is that if it's just a if
you think of this as of to normal as
long as you're not gaussian this equal
to three means it's a gaussian as long
as you're not gaussian the local Minima
will be the columns it's best to make U
transpose equal to a column of
a okay uh so so so this this so there
proof is not just not gaussian you
actually have to be not gaussian in the
fourth moment so a little bit stronger
it works for the Q cube is not gum in
the
fourth okay so that's the thing these
things have been generalized to you know
more general you know arbitary
distributions as long as they're not
gaussian underdetermined ICA and so on
and so forth to gaussian noise so what
if your data was also shifted by some
special kind of noise but the problem
that that we're talk about today is what
if this arbitrary noise what do I mean
by that so here's the data
that you would get from the true
distribution after shifted after after a
fine transformation but you don't see
this an adversary arbitrarily corrupts
an Epsilon fraction so they can take out
some they can add new points whatever
they want up to Epsilon fraction of the
points they can do whatever they want
we'll discuss the model formally in a
second arbit corrupted by adversary can
you still learn the parallel pipid
within total variation distance Epsilon
in principle yes because you only change
the Epsilon fraction of the
mass Okay so T distance is the natural
notion here when you have arbitary
Corruptions
um and it would be the best possible
guarantee because you could really
remove so that's the problem we're going
to talk
about sorry I think I got confused yes
if it's gum like it would work you just
don't care right
or sorry I guess like yeah yeah it just
wouldn't be unique the solution would be
unique okay but if you care about
learning in TV distance like then it
would be trivial
exactly you don't even need to see any
points um right so uh yeah so that's
what's happening so somebody has
transformed an Epsilon fraction of the
points and you'd like to recover still
the original Cube okay now so here's out
of the talk algorithmic robust
statistics I'll do a couple of slides um
uh moments do not suffice we'll see that
uh TV estimation can still be done it's
going an efficient algorithm of near
optimal error combinator l and some
researchs okay um and I think finish by
11:45 okay robot statistics you know
this is a classical topic but there's
been a Resurgence over the last 10 years
there's
been several workshops here at
assignments uh in but the question is
just you want to estimate statistical
quantities but some of your data is not
from the distribution you're trying to
estimate rather it's been arbitrarily
corrupted okay uh it's turned into a
very nice field
um um and you still want to so the point
is you want to estimate the underlying
model despite arbitrary Corruptions
learning sometimes
agnostic uh right and uh this is a this
is challenging because you know even
simple things like the mean are totally
affected by changing a tiny fraction one
point so uh so that's the that's the
that's the overall problem there are
many interesting problems of course you
can ask for estimating basic quantities
like mean and covariance you can
estimate TR ask for gaussian a mixture
of gaussians hidden Mark of model and so
on and classical approaches are either
NP hard to implement computationally or
their error scales for the dimension as
opposed to just the error the the the
fraction of Corruptions what you would
like is that the error should scale with
fraction of Corruptions not no
dependence on the
damage um So within
TCS in 2016 there paper that showed that
the so if you take basically single
gaussian or generalization of this to
nice distributions you can actually
estimate uh it robustly in time in in
with error depending slightly more than
Epsilon but no dependence on the
dimension Dimension F dependence and
this is essentially the best possible uh
there's now a a monograph by De and Kane
which describes this approach but also
lots of applications
over the
past seven years
yeah uh one of the culminating points
here is actually the problem that led me
to this robust Statistics question was
uh uh can you estimate a mixture of K
gaussians in polinomial time when you
have arbitrary Corruptions you know your
statistics model is never exactly right
there's a bit that's not doesn't fit the
model and while the problem without
noise was solved very nicely in 2010 by
kimra Valiant those algorithms don't
work if you have even a little bit of
noise coms out that you do have
polinomial time algorithms now uh even
with Epsilon noise the very different
algorithm so
nice um yeah that's that's a quick
summary of this but here is something
that underlies every robust statistics
algorithm I know the key Insight is that
what you use is robust estimates of
moments moments of of the data okay and
in fact
from the moments you can argue that the
underlying distribution is fixed up to
the error that's that you can't avoid
because of Corruptions this was already
something that Pearson when he was
talking about single G moments was
hyping but it's now much more
quantitative now of course given the
robust estimates of moments recovering
distribution is still a challenging
algorithmic task but at least
information theoretically moments seem
to give you everything you need for all
this including the mixture of G and so
on
okay so for for gaussians of course you
know stand out the for mixture of K
gaans
yeah you can do with a finite number
moments um and the moments can be
estimated robustly so of course the
natural question approach is estimate
the moments robustly even though you've
corrupted Epsilon fra estimate the mean
robustly the true mean within smaller
and then use those robust estimates to
recover whatever you want and and that
that second part I'm saying in a
sentence but it's quite challenging okay
but but the estimation of the moments at
least for a large class of distributions
can be done in poly
time so this follows
from Kari steinard ster that constant
degree moments you can actually robustly
estimate
okay now um yeah as I mentioned that's
that's that's sort of information Theory
and getting those part then you still
need to go the rest now how about a
parallel Piper
right so we want to learn parallel pip
in TV
distance uh let's say order Epsilon
rather than
Epsilon so there's a simple
solution you think about it for a minute
you'll see that you give the you give me
all this data some of it is corrupted
and I find the smallest volume parallel
pipid that contains one minus Epsilon of
the
points and that will actually be uh uh
within one minus order Epsilon of the
underlying true
now of course this problem how do you
find the smallest volume par that's a
hard
problem and so on in fact it's it's
reminiscent of some of the early
statistic Solutions like 2 key propos
the median so in 1D the robust estimate
of the mean is the median great but in
higher Dimensions what what does median
mean it's kind of complicated things
like me median along every direction is
not a good idea you get errors depending
on Dimension but there is a nice idea
which is you find a a minimum volume
ellipsoid that contains say half the
points if you could do that that mean of
that is a great estimate and also now
that's of course how how do you find a
minimum volume ellipsoid that contains
similar to this how do you find a
minimum volume parall Piper that
contains 1us
epon okay so let's take a simpler
problem forget about a fine
transformation all I'm going to do is a
shift I've got a cube it stays a cube
standard Cube but it's shifted I don't
tell you what the shift is and your
points are going to be corrupted Epsilon
fraction
okay now this should be easy right all
you need to estimate is the
mean so if you didn't have Corruptions
you just estimate the sample mean you're
done but you have
Corruptions but that's kind of the basic
problem we solved in robust statistics
right estimate the mean
robustly doesn't work you see
because um if I shift the mean by an
Epsilon
distance and in every coordinate that
could be Epsilon over square root D
diagonal shift right Epsilon root D the
L2 Norm is Epsilon the total variation
distance is Epsilon Time Square Root D
because in every coordinate I've lost
Epsilon over root D of the mass and
there are D coordinates so the overlap
between these two is only one minus is
only 1 minus Epsilon root
d right so the total variation distance
is huge so if you give me somebody
that's shifted Epsilon you could be
totally off
we got the wrong Cube yes but the point
is somehow like if you knew how to
rotate then you would be okay right this
there's no rotation no no no if you if
you if you changed your uh coordinate so
that it's not a diagonal shift you
rotate your coordinate system then
you're only moving along One
Direction yes yeah we don't know of
course which direction was moved and uh
yeah yeah yeah but but kind of hint at
finding the direction right because
isn't that what to some extent these
filtering algorithms do is is there some
well there there the nice thing about
about in in the gaussian setting of s
you can you so you can estimate the mean
within L2 distance Epsilon you don't
care its basis independent right and and
also normalized L2 and so on here the
trouble is that there is an underlying
basis that we don't know about and with
respect to that basis L2 distance can be
terrible yeah and there is no way of
find no me that's part of the problem
yeah you want to figure out that basis
right
yeah yeah I mean in this case we even
know the basis but we don't know which
shift I'm telling you the cube is given
to you and only thing you're doing is
Shifting it yeah right so uh that's the
challenge and same thing with
rotation uh if I rotate even by an
Epsilon uh then uh then the TV distance
shoots up to Epsilon time
D okay so now the point is that moments
actually do not provably not suffice
because for any constant degree actually
degree up to log D over log log D the
moments will stay close what you would
get from errors Absol but uh but but
meanwhile the TV distance is huge so
moments just don't have information
theoretically enough content to tell you
the
answer whereas for without noise moments
great fourth moment
done and Gan mix case you know K moments
so there's an interesting problem here
right we need a new algorithm yes so
just checking so you're saying even all
the cross
movements yeah yeah yeah the degree yeah
the full tensor I give you the entire I
give you the tensor up to log D little
low log D or log log
D yes just you can just compute it in
check okay so we need a new certificate
of what it means to be
CL okay so let's take uh the simple case
again shift but I I'll also throw in
diagonal scaling allowed to to to shift
but also scale individual coordinates it
can become a
box so first thing to note is that
certainly the total variation distance
between the true uh uh box and your box
any other box is at most the sum of the
distances along every marginal so if I
just bound the total variation distance
along every marginal that's just a like
Union bound it's an upper bound
okay um and uh yeah because in any one
coordinate because these are just
intervals you can say that the total
variation distance is basically the mean
divided by the by the standard
deviation so you know if you shift if if
they were all the same standard
deviation say unit then it would
be as much as the mean
shift so let's just assume that the that
the standard deviations are one no
scaling so now what it's saying is that
it's sufficient to
estimate the the the mean shift not in
L2 Norm but in L1 Norm because that
bound the distance you want Epsilon
error in L1
Norm that's impossible in general you
can't do for example just not possible
epon Corruptions can make the AL
eror so here's what here's the algorithm
it's very simple lot of build up but
algorithm is simple uh you start with a
course approximation along every
coordinate you know take an interval
that contains a little bit more than
half double it that contain almost the
entire data set and do that along every
coordinate that you start with that you
will be within TV distance you know that
will contain almost all the points but
you might be very big and now let me put
the figures up there are just two things
two operations that will repeat
iteratively the first operation is we
try to move so this is your estimate of
the box that's the true box this is your
estimate because you just doubled
something to make sure you catch most of
the points along every coordinate you
try to shift down if you can what's your
rule for shifting down you look at a
small interval of wickness thickness
about Epsilon over D and you see if the
density there the fraction of points
there is much smaller than what you
would expect in the cube in the cube
it's uniform right thickness thickness T
should have points about t here you're
checking if it's less than that by some
big constant okay two say if it's less
than half what it should be if it is
then you move in and you do that
separately for every coordinate if your
density is less than a constant Factor
times what you expect it to be where did
the true Cube you move in that's the
first series the second one and this is
crucial you look at the intersection of
these slabs pairwise just two slabs at a
time now in there if you were the true
Cube there would be only an Epsilon
Square I mean if there was was a Delta
fraction here and a Delta fraction here
the intersection would have only Delta
squar because we're talking about the
uniform distribution so if you find that
the density is too high say more than 10
times what you expect it to be then
there must be noise all of them just
throw out
everything okay now the point is you
most of what you're throwing out is
noise you might throw a little bit of
true point you don't care you have
Epsilon you might get two Epsilon so
that's it these are the two operations
you keep doing this as much as you can
do this do this do this do this do this
while you can and stop that's the whole
algorithm and then you can guarantee
that what you end up with will be four
Epsilon K
distance okay and here's a this is the
entire proof out line here let's say for
a second that your noise only affects
one coordinate every noisy point that
means either a point that was deleted or
a new point that was added has a label
of which coordinate is affecting it's
only allowed to affect any one
coordinate of course that's not true
let's just assume that then in that case
the total budget for noisy points is
only Epsilon n right and so every all
the errors that you make every time you
change the density by factor of two
you're paying proportional to the amount
of noise and so you can't pay more than
order and
total so that's the and of course what
you're removing is order Epsilon that's
just period because every time you
remove you're removing mostly
noise but this assumption is kind of uh
crazy right why of course coord noise
can affect multiple coordinates if I put
them in intersection they can affect
multiple coordinates I might have
deleted it but might still doesn't make
sense because it could be in the middle
of two slabs and so
on okay so for this we have this
SL and I'll write it down on the board
just in case you know you don't care
about estimating a fine Transformations
but you like probability I mean
commentor lemas you can try
to okay so you have subsets of N and
this is just kind of the fraction the
relative size d subsets D won't matter
but some finite number of
subsets and the union takes up only
Epsilon end
points right the union of all the
subsets takes up only Epsilon
n and I tell you that the intersection
of any pair is is at most Alpha
times the product of the
fractions okay so every subset if if I
look at a pair of subsets the
intersection size is at most Alpha 10
five some Alpha times the fractions
taken up by these
subsets Alpha is greater than zero and
Alpha times Epsilon is less than one
then the sum of the sizes of these
subsets the fractions of these subsets
just the Su is outside now not inside is
at most Epsilon 1 minus Alon so in other
words the sum of these subsets where
you're potentially counting things
multiple times is at most the size of
the Union divided by a small factor so
it's it's proportional to the union so
if I think of this as much smaller than
one it's it's order of the Union the sum
of the sides are order of the Union okay
so that's the
LMA and
uh this allows us to say
that you can treat each coordinate
separately and your cumulative effect
you won't have thrown out
much um scaling which I didn't describe
here is an easy extension so I will put
up this here now to prove this comes
down to a little probability
Lemma let me implies that so let's see I
think we have time so is that you have
S1 through St they are all subsets of n
and I won't even Define the fraction let
me just say that the union of
Si the size of this is Epsilon
n and Si intersect SJ the size of this
is smaller than divided by n is smaller
than Alpha times size of Si divided by n
times size of SJ divid n that's the
condition for all
IG and I this implies
that the sum of the sizes of
Si is at most the union of the sizes of
Si of course this this is the wrong
inequality but I divide by 1 minus
Alpha it's not quite inclusion exclusion
right okay
and the hint if you
like
this is
um uh now moving to probability these
are just um random
variables but they are 01
indicators and we assume that the
expectation of uh X ixj is at most
Epsilon times expectation of XI times
expectation of XJ so they're negatively
correlated by
some then I want to say this implies
that the sum of the
expectations is at most one
over-
yeah the pro will be fit here
so should need to use don't want to okay
so that's that's that takes care of
shift and scaling what about
rotation this is more challenging yes
the shift thing
yes like if I told you uh there's this
box it has some hidden shift you have to
return to me a box of exactly the same
size that has close in TV distance yeah
the box size doesn't match pretty
closely then the TV distance will become
too big yeah I guess what I mean is if
you if you're restricted to be like
proper learning of this box like you
have to learn exactly the same size is
that equivalent to estimating the mean
and the L1 norm and therefore hard like
is the magic of how like how are you
avoiding the hardness of estimating the
mean of the L1 Norm is this because
you're allowed to change the size of the
Box slightly to like no it's because of
the actual algorithm itself when we when
we do these iteration where we remove
stuff from the pairwise
intersections that heavily affects I
that it's no longer just estimation of
moments right okay whereas those those
those intersections don't affect the
moments but they do affect
the L1 Norm okay okay so you can't like
back out some estimate of the mean you
could try to back out an estimate of the
mean from your new distri so at the end
of the day at the end of the day when
the algorithm stops I can output the
center of the box as the mean yeah but
this is not going to be good in the L1
Norm no this will be good in the L1 it
will be Oh I thought you couldn't this
will be good in the L1 Norm oh okay okay
what I'm saying is that if you estimated
the
original uh from the sample the robust
okay and
so you could think about this as a Rob
as I'll state in a second it is
essential to estimate the mean and the
the because it's going to be equivalent
in TV yeah that's what I was wondering
if it's equivalent okay okay thanks I
got
it okay so how what do we do with
rotation but once again we let let's say
just pure rotation no scaling right no
scaling no shift I just rotated
arbitrarily there's a there's a rotation
Matrix I need to estimate so once again
we can start with a course estimate so
that we can get by um either a sum of
squares program or a careful filtering
where um basically the Matrix a can be
estimated by some Matrix a hat so that a
minus a hat is small in say say two that
means that in particular every column
the two Nom error is square root Epsilon
that's of course going to give you a
huge TV distance error but that's a
starting point it's like a warm start
all right uh right now
what now here's the the Lemma it says so
so so this is I'm I'm stting it here for
for the normal vectors but it's also for
the
mean so if you look at the ttal
variation distance between an
orthonormal A and any other a hat right
take any a hat not necessarily
orthonormal H is the cube so it's it's
some rotation of the cube and some other
ass sign trans I mean linear
transformation of the cube then this
total variation distance is bounded
between a constant absolute constant
times the sum of the
L2 errors and it's also lowerer binded
by the sum of the L2 errors with a
smaller
constant okay so the sum of the L2
errors in in your vectors gives you
actually the the TV distance so if you
only estimated this to within Epsilon of
course You' get Epsilon times D here
it's too much right so it's not enough
to do each one and so we need to get
this tighter we need to estimate each AI
within something like Epsilon over D
much
closer and even if you estimated the
entire Matrix in fenus Norm that won't
suffice because Fus Norm would be some
of the squares of these would be Epsilon
but then this could be Epsilon root
D okay so how do we estimate the
rotation so first let's assume no
outliers it's a case we already know how
to do but but let's it's going to be a
new
algorithm so we start with the co course
estimates and we're going to do a local
optimization so we have a starting point
right and we know the true AI is
somewhere near to this AI head that I
started with I should do something local
optimization local search right um how
do we do local search gradi in descent
okay one second yeah so how do we do
that we have to be a little bit more
careful let's consider so this is where
you are this is your current Cube okay
that's the true Cube you want to get so
that you have this error but you don't
know where that true cube is it could be
anywhere within square root Epsilon of
you so consider this cap you know you
have this box here look at this this
half space and there's also the
complimentary half space
here so s of a here and minus a for one
coordinate I'm focusing on this one one
normal and that has a
mean right s I've reflected this over
here and that has a mean here that mean
is telling you something about the
region of
error okay and what you're going to do
is use that mean to tell you which way
to direct to rotate the point is that
that mean is going to be is dragging you
is dragging a hat away from a so you
should move opposite to that mean and
that's exactly what we'll do we're going
to shift a some you know learning rate
parameter times this mu divid and
normalize keeping it unit vectors
remember this is just a rotation so I
want to keep unit vectors so I estimate
the mean of the difference and move
opposite that not too much a little bit
right okay and this actually converges
there's no noise so far this converges
to the to the right a
Prov so what we're trying to do is I
have this candidate facet which is
closed and I'm trying to move it so as
to minimize the cap whatever is sticking
out okay and I have that because I
samples I mean I get samples from the
true Cube up to Epsilon error there
there's no error right now so I really
get samples from the true Cube and so
I'm using this cap and of course that
cap will be minimized if I rotate it
towards the true a and that's what the
proof would
say okay okay so this was great without
noise but we already know how to do this
without noise how about doing it
robustly so we go back here same picture
we going to estimate the same mean
except
remember now it's not just here mean
points could be anywhere because Epsilon
fraction have been orbitally
corrupted and in fact this might be
empty even in some
cases what we'll do is that we'll use
robust mean estimation So within the
Caps we'll estimate the mean of the set
robustly that's the point that means
that the true mean minus this mean is
going to be is going to have a tiny
difference and that we can do we know
how to do and this is a nice enough set
it's still going to be a convex set you
can estimate the mean nicely and uh uh
uh and that's the whole algorithm so
this is the robust algorithm start with
a course estimate of axis you define
these half spaces for each coordinate
with
your um now you have to check the
density of pairwise intersections like
this this is all you have the Orange is
all you have the blue is your gold which
you don't know you look at the pairwise
intersections of these slabs if it's too
high you're still going to throw out
stuff okay points and now you repeat
this this robust gradient descent where
you want to use the mean of this this
this region that's sticking out to move
your a hat and but every time you do
that you make a little little little
move the LMA will say you you make you
get close
you replace the deleted points because
you can't afford to delete so many
points you delete them for the purpose
of estimation and then you put them back
do it again do it again do again that's
the delog D times and on the way you
will get all these
candidates we can of course test whether
the candidates are good because we can
get new samples and test how close it is
to
distribution and and the guarantee is
that this gives you an a hat which is
closed in TV distance
to now underl this are a couple of lemas
I just describe that's the theorem
that's the update and and and and the
geometric facts we'll use are actually
specific to the cube so one of the open
problems will be to try to do this in
more General product distributions we
don't know how to do this really use
properties of the hyper
Cube um here here are three
properties maybe the first property is
suppose I have a hat you know is close
to the true EI Within
some distance Delta distance is Delta
then the volume of this cap is between
constant times Delta and slightly more
than a different constant than Del very
close doesn't matter where you are
because I mean that's not a non-trivial
statement right if I if I do it in 2D of
course that's easy because it's just a
triangle but if I rotate the slab in an
arbitrary Direction you want to say that
the volume of the cap the difference is
within is proportional to Delta and we
need to know the constants to to make
this whole analysis so that's that's
property one property two is that the
mean in the cap is a little bit less
than one strictly less than one by this
Delta it's actually know it's not one
it's a little bit less than
one and then property three is that the
variance of uh of of points in this in
this vision is is is is T it's only
Delta squ so standard is also about
Delta okay so these fact together will
imply that there is a learning rate beta
so that when I apply the update in fact
it drops by you know you get closer to
the Target by one minus
con yes can you say a little bit more
about how you like get this sneak out
this extra factor of n like in ter like
uh I thought the point was you need to
learn like each direction to like L2 ER
Epsilon Over N but it seems like this
sort of recursion would bottom out at
Epsilon if the adversaries like oh we're
doing this separately for each
coordinate right and uh you're saying
what if replace all its noise in one
side yeah great so so what we're going
to say is that we do this for every
coordinate that sum of all the errors is
Epsilon n there will be some coordinates
where it works yeah and we'll just keep
track of about d square candidates and
do take the
best okay so yeah good question and then
and so you make this
progress and now the general case
remember we did shift and scaling and
rotation General aine transformation is
is has all three elements we're just
going to alternate between shift and
scaling and rotation you do shift and
scaling to the extent you can when it
stops you do estimate rotation go back
to shift and scaling and and go back and
forth and the point is that the
termination for each phase of say
rotation gives you either you've
perfectly estimated the shift and
scaling or you'll make progress and and
so they the bootstrap and converge to uh
the correct solution and so the final
theorem is that given an Epsilon
corrupted sample arbitr corrupted sample
of
a linear transformation applied to the
cube plus a shift there is a randomized
polom Time algorithm that outputs a
parallel piped a hat small a hat so that
the TV distance is
actually this is very different
algorithm without noise also right this
it's actually grading descent it's not
saying compute the fourth moment and
that's giving you your direction you
start with some course estimate and you
do gr
descent um robust estimation needs to go
beyond moment estimation and this is the
first problem I it does and there's a
different parameterization of robust
estimation it's not the moment
distance show up in places and student
haia worked on this for two years
despite mild um suggestions that maybe
it's time to work on something
else
um uh open problems no no that the
animation error okay can can this be
done for General product
distributions okay General product
distributions which we know how to do
ICA without noise we don't know with
noise or is there some lurking hardness
maybe there's some distribution I don't
know so you know one natural thing would
be product of low concave distributions
for
example okay um but here's one of my
favorite problems I give you uniform
random points from an unknown polyhedron
so not a cube but a polyhedron okay but
okay uh bounded poly right so it's some
number M facets okay and you want to
estimate the polyon to within TV
distance
Epsilon okay and uh the sample
complexity is only order MD over Epsilon
if you have M facets in D Dimensions
this the VC Dimensions M * D so you
don't need more than this information
theoretically MD over Epsilon sample so
you can find the
poly is there qu time algorithm we don't
know it without noise either by the way
without nois is open with noise is open
we know how to do cubes maybe we know
how to do
Simplex thank
you time for
questions so how important is the like
the crude estimate like can't you just
start with anything can do gradient
descent or yeah the crude estimate does
for our analysis at least seems
important because the Improvement in the
error requires that the distance between
where you start and the target is
smaller than with anybody else um by a
big constant if he started in principle
at least I I implemented this you just
pick a random Direction run the gradi
robust gradient descent or just creting
this it'll converge to a facet it does
that for polyedra too so by the way
here's an algorithm for General learning
General poly forget about noise look at
an Direction okay uh uh look at the uh
go all up to the point where you have
like Epsilon fraction of mass keep Epson
and now uh do local search to minimize
the the the the the the volume there and
that the variance
there it's
here so your one of the first things you
talked about like as a possible solution
was to find the minimum volume and Clos
in parallel pipid that contains oneus
EPS fraction of the points is the
problem still difficult if instead of
General parallel tyod you just want to
have a box I'm asking because of the
first set of results yeah you mean find
a find a just a box yeah you don't have
a rotation it's still it's still because
um the choices are coordinated yeah I
mean we end up finding approxim that
because any solution must be close to
that uh so that would have been a
related question so for what you do with
your algorithm does it what what are the
implications on the volume of yeah so
the volume is is is is close to the
within within Epsilon of the order
Epsilon of the of the optimum minimum
volume it has to be otherwise the TV
distance is too high sense
thanks
I'll ask a question uh this is a very
like nice and clean algorithm but can
you make it more
complicated can you uh like can you do
this with some thinking the stuff
right can you do it with some of squares
like so oh yeah yeah so the first part
which I skipped over which was how do
you find the warm start I mean it was
done in 2017 to estimate this Matrix a
but uh that uh the original algorithm
and even now if you want sort of the
algorithm you can give in a lecture and
prove it would be a sum of squares
algorithm to find the to find the
original course estimate of the rotation
but I don't mean the course I guess I'm
asking whether you can do the whole
thing within the sum of squares
framework no not clear at all right not
clear at
all so there could be some kind of
Separation I mean in fact you know there
are these heuristic arguments that some
of squares is basically allowing you to
do whatever moments can do and so on
yeah so either Su squares is doing more
than that which it possibly could be
with the right constraints uh uh and
then you to figure out how and that
would be interesting uh but uh but no no
not not
clear uh just to follow up on that what
is the difficult step like in terms like
uh which which
constraints uh used by your stopping
condition or hard to encode as Pol I
mean any any any of this I mean I want
to say that the pairwise intersection of
the SL I mean I don't know how to write
a convex relaxation of the whole
algorithm but the pair wise intersection
is not too large yeah
so how how about a
general just the problem you mentioned
finding
minimum yeah that's
NP to approximate yeah I mean if you
don't give me yeah wait a minute
the that's the inner John ellipsoid no
point oh wait no no there's arbitrary
noise so oh I see I see yeah yeah so you
could in principle have to try out two
to the Epsilon and choices before you
know what see the arbitrary corruption
makes that a challenge so if you could
do that this if you could find the
minimum volume then you're done
ellipsoid would't suffice in this case
you'd have to find the same shape that
you're looking for but minimum volume
ellipsoid would solve the problem of
robust mean estimation let's say for a
gaussian along the lines of looking at
uh other distributions than this uniform
and a so are there like other examples
of LP balls where we know how to do
stuff because for example for the L2
ball rotation rate it doesn't make any
difference so great question yeah I
think L1 so I mentioned Simplex but
basically L1 ball I think but every Lama
has to be done so it's we're missing the
right proof but you so basically in the
cube I really use these properties of
the cube that we proved looked in it we
couldn't find maybe they're not
interesting on their own but about how
the volume changes near the boundaries
in arbitrary directions you know uh how
much volume the mean of what you cut off
and the variance of of that region these
things we would need to establish within
tight sufficiently tight constant
factors if true for those bodies so I I
believe that it can be done for the
Simplex but there is not a proof written
down yet and therefore for the L1 ball I
see thanks
than uh basic question I can't res it
can't resist because it came up again
sorry so is it B directional in the
sense that like uh if you have solved
the problem you must have found a
polytope on a Epsilon n fraction of the
points that has sufficiently small
volume yeah you you would have find
found a point fra uh you would have
found a parallel piped that contains uh
at least one minus some constant Epsilon
points whose volume is close to the to
the to the to the to the minimum yeah
thank
you yeah I mean do you have time for
this
unless yeah okay um uh
yeah okay if somebody else wants to come
up and do it you're welcome too also so
I I'll Pro of course LMA 2 first and
what does that uh say we have to look at
it's the the the thing on the left hand
side is a sum of the expectations
right uh so we got a square it and then
I use one of this crowd's favorite
inequalities which is starts with a J
yeah so which will be what uh which will
become expectation
of uh sum of
XI squar okay so far so good and now let
me expand I have the summation of
expectation of
That's
So of expectation if you don't pull it
oh sorry sorry what did I what did I
miss out this this Square goes inside
the expect thank
you um do I want to put the square here
but the expectation is on the yeah thank
yeah x i s yeah so far so good plus uh I
not equal to
J um expectation of x i XJ
good and now uh this is the same because
these are 01
variables this is the same as
expectation of XI good and now I'll put
less than equal to the condition we
assumed on the expect on the correlation
right says that this is at most
Epsilon times the summation of
expectation x i expectation XJ I'll
throw in the I equal to J terms here
it's a non negative random variable and
so I'll end up with expectation of XI
twice squared so now that goes to the
left hand side because it's the same as
the left hand side and so we get that
summation of expectation of x i over I
is at most one over 1 minus Epsilon
because one term cancels okay so that's
the
the correlation inequality
now this yeah it took me one week but I
was hoping
somebody um now here how does how about
this
one uh like we just have to set up the
right random variables right so let me
pick Y
uniformly in Union of
Si okay and let's define XI
as zero if Y is not in
si and one if Y is in
si Okay now what's the expectation of
XI it's the size of Si divided by the
union of the size of the
UN and then what's the expectation of XI
time
XJ um no uh equal to
so this only is one if both it's in both
so it's s i intersect
SJ divided by the size of the good and
now we can verify because of the
Assumption on the SI intersect SJ that
yes I know I'm sorry I don't want to
distract you by almost falling um is at
most how much uh Alpha size of Si times
size of
SJ is this oh you can't Anything Can
you um divide so uh am I doing this um
too messy yeah
let's just verify oh
right um let's see so I want to bound
this using the Assumption we made I'm
trying to write it cleanly what is it
saying that this is at
most
um um Alpha
SI SJ I have a single n good and Union
of
Si
okay and now let's also write another
Union of Si and write here Union of Si
divide by n so this is how much Alpha
this is
Epsilon and this is uh um expectation of
XI and this is expectation of
XJ so it satisfies the condition with
constant Alpha Epsilon condition of LMA
2 now we apply LMA 2 by LMA 2 we have
that the sum of the expectation of x i
over I is at
most 1/ 1 minus Alpha Epsilon because
Alpha Epsilon is the constant but what
is the expectation of XI it's size of Si
divid by un SI so this is just saying
summation over I of the size of Si is at
most
size of Union of Si divid 1 minus
Al right so the sum of the sizes is at
most the union this is the Epsilon so I
don't
sorry all right
[Applause]
[Music]
let and uh if anyone has a a question
about the algebra they can they can do
that
offline so we'll reconvene at 1:30 now
there's a lunch
break